Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full Marvels movie breakdown.
Easter Eggs for the entire film.
There are a bunch of references.
obviously some of the bigger ones in the post-credits
scenes that everybody's talking about.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
real big week that Marvel is having between this
in the Loki Season two finale.
In big coincidence, too, Tom Hiddleston's partner
in real life was playing Dar-Benn Zawe Ashton here.
They actually just had a baby together, I don't think
they plan on releasing both of their projects here.
Like, it just kind of worked out that way,
there's a little bit of connection
between what's happening in the Marvels movie
and Loki Season two, but not that much of a connection.
mostly the craziness just in general in the multiverse
is happening during the events of Loki Season two.
Like this kind of influencing everything
that's happening in the Marvel Universe right now,
part of the big lead up to Avengers five, Qing Dynasty,
and then fighting the Council of Kang's.
The Incursion storyline, though, is also leading up
to Avengers six secret wars where all the incursions
finally topple basically the rest of the multiverse,
like all of reality, starts to collapse on itself.
So that stuff is going to be bad news for Loki,
who's like sitting at the center of the multiverse.
Now. but essentially that was like the biggest concept
that they did during
the movie is basically showing you
what an incursion actually looks like
when two universes begin to collide with each other.
But before we get too deep into the weeds,
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the movie yet,
we'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through, shot by shot,
Talking about Easter eggs wtf moments.
Obviously a bunch of X-Men teasers
starting with the new Marvel logo intro.
They added a bunch of scenes of Monica Rambeau
and Kamala Khan just to sort of catch people up.
I think on who they are.
If they didn't watch the Ms
Marvel series or they didn't watch Wandavision
technically, they designed the movie to sort of catch
you up really quickly at the beginning
about who they were, what their powers weren't like,
just how everything works.
But if you did watch the series,
I think it benefited you a lot more as a viewer.
There are a couple of new scenes of Monica Rambeau
during Wandavision one in her 1970s
outfit with the Afro
when Scarlet Witch was my controlling her.
There's a scene of her using her powers
for the first time when Scarlet Witch was attacking her
after she'd passed through the Hex to remind people
that she does have powers.
this is a new scene in Ms Marvel from Ms
Marvel episode one, where she put her bangle on
for the first time and it fully activated
or started activating her mutant powers,
basically activating her x gene.
a scene here of Captain Marvel during the first Captain
Marvel movie with her sunglasses
about to go out on a tense flight with Maria
Rambeau essentially is there for Maria Rambeau
Because Maria is a big character
during the film in a couple of different ways,
like both in the flashbacks in the main 616
version of the character, but also in the post-credits
scene with the binary version of the character.
there's also a couple of moments during the movie
where they get into their memories, the Desert Explorer
and Captain Marvel's memories, and you see that
she actually talked to Maria about how she thought that
Maria should have been the person on the day
that she got powers to have been that person,
which they've already done
a couple of different versions of,
like the one in Doctor Strange
Multiverse of Madness in the 838
universe was the one that got powers that day.
She flew the tests like got the powers
and it turns out the same thing or something similar
happened in the X-Men universe at the end of the movie,
where she became the binary version of the character.
there's a brand new Captain Marvel theme song
that they play over the opening titles.
In the actual opening scene is of Carrie's Dying Son,
with Darwyn taking their flee to an alien world
where they've discovered the second bangle,
which they reveal are the quantum bands of Quasar
from the comics lot of you
saw her hammer in the trailers and wondered about this.
They confirmed that is Ronan, the accuser's hammer.
They're calling it the universal weapon,
which is what he uses in the comics,
basically a very powerful hammer that's not like
the other hammers that the other accuser Corey uses.
Not quite as powerful as like stormbreaker or mutineer,
but really,
really powerful even by itself
without the extra power of some of the Bangles.
Basically, the idea is that it can interface
with the power of other really powerful artifacts,
like the Infinity Stones during the first Guardians
of the Galaxy movie
that Ronan used, and also the Power of the Bangles.
in essentially during the movie she's
using the Bangles power in combination with the Hammer
to force open
brand new jump points, unstable jump points
to steal resources from different planets
and bring them to the Kree Homeworld.
HeLa supposedly there was going to be a deleted scene
that would have taken place before this moment here
of her finding the second bangle, explaining
the history behind the original Quasar know, his bands
wound up here on this planet, but also the other one
went up on Earth in that ten rings temple lake.
I don't think that that creed
that was wearing it, like they found a cree's hand
in the rubble with the bangle on.
I don't think that was meant to be the original Quasar.
But basically there's this conceit
in the Marvel Universe,
like the MCU of all these jump points
around the universe.
They explained that the quantum bands
were used to create that jump network
in the comics,
the quantum bands are kind of like Green Lantern rings.
They're powered by the quantum realm.
That's why they're called the quantum bands.
They're usually bestowed on
whoever becomes the next quasar.
James Gunn actually just introduced the final oval
version of Quasar, who was like the second version
of the character in the comics.
She doesn't need the quantum bands to use her powers,
like the way that the high evolutionary created her,
The back stories.
It's a little bit different for the MCU,
So it's kind of like Kamala Khan
is now like Kamala Khan can use her powers
without the Bangles.
Interestingly enough, Side Tangent,
the quantum bands also gave Sanders's parents
a large and sweet scan of Titan Eternals
The ability to have biological children,
explaining how eternal robots are able to have children
like Thanos and his brother Eros.
there, even wound up being a bunch of replicas
of the bands in the comics that Thanos created
using the Infinity Gantlet in one of the pairs wound up
in the hands of the blue Marvel Adam Bruce years.
He's not a character in the movie, though
There are a lot of questions like this character here.
This was not the Blue Marvel.
da. Been the main villain of the movie, played by Zoe
Ashton, is the character from the comics,
but they changed her a lot from the comics.
And the whole idea is that the Kree race
over this collapse after Captain Marvel killed the Kree
Supreme Intelligence, also explained that in the MCU,
the supreme intelligence
was actually artificial intelligence
that drove them to war, that initially started
the Chris Skrull war because it just felt like
it was the optimal direction for their race to go.
But the whole idea is that a civil war
erupted like a power struggle
in the vacuum
left by the absence of the supreme intelligence.
And it wound up destroying their planet,
basically causing their son to almost out
I don't know what happened during their civil war
because their son, two, almost died billions of years
before it was supposed to.
must have been a really nasty war, thus
they dubbed Captain Marvel the Annihilator,
which they referenced a couple of times in the movie,
which is a reference to a couple different things.
like, it's a reference to the nihilist character
from the Fantastic Four comics to the Annihilation
storyline in the comics, which a lot of the Guardians
of the Galaxy story is based on in the movies.
James Gunn also said for like a hot second,
a nihilist was going to be
the main villain of Guardians of the Galaxy
three in the person who would have created a rocket.
But it would obviously been a much different version
of the character from the comics.
He's mostly a fantastic Four character,
so maybe we'll see him
in the Fantastic Four sequels at some point,
or like the Annihilation Wave.
basically, Dar-Benn was there when Captain Marvel
came to kill the Kree Supreme Intelligence.
She was wounded
and basically blames Captain Marvel for everything bad
that's happened to their race since then,
which obviously is false, I guess obviously a bad idea,
but she was meant to be pretty crazy already.
When the movie starts.
The movie jumps back to Jersey City
and we see the sign.
This was actually featured
in all the end credits scenes for the Ms
Marvel series
they basically give us like a tutorial in Ms.
Marvels character, kind of catching people up,
what her powers are like, how she works as a character
just in general.
this scene is meant to take place before the Ms
Marvel Episode six Post-Credits scene because we later
see that during the events of the movie,
pretty much everything around
her room is the exact same from that Ms
Marvel Post-Credits scene.
These are her friends from school, Bruno and Nakia.
There's a bunch of Avengers art,
Captain Marvel art around her room.
A lot of the Captain
Marvel art in the pictures are a combination of panels
just taken directly from the comics,
like they are comic book panels in real life,
and some are actually taken from real life promotions
from the first movie.
like there's a lot of Brie Larson pictures
as Captain Marvel.
It's just basically taken from posters
for the first movie, I think some of the toys
she has around her room, too, are also stuff
that got sold by Marvel in real life.
Notice in the background, zoom in Enhances.
Is there a YouTube channel Loft Baby Productions
where she makes her Avengers fan films?
You know, she's using her powers to do casual things
like closing the door so her mother can't hear
the story she's working on here like the giant
robot adventures she's having with Captain Marvel.
Like her little fanfiction is based on the Chris
century character, which is a comic book character.
They actually use the character
during the animated Fantastic Four series.
It was voiced by Mark Hamill, Luke Skywalker himself,
the way they animate her story while she's reciting
it is the same way they did for her Avengers Endgame
fan films in Ms
Marvel Episode one Notice in her notes
here on the page.
The word parallel is written a couple of times.
I think that's meant to be foreshadowing
for the parallel universes that Monica Rambeau
gets stuck in at the end of the movie.
Then when her mother interrupts her again,
we find out that she's already back in her suit.
And they have the events of the Miss Marvel
Post-Credits scene where she swaps with Captain Marvel
for the first time, but they stop it short,
like as she's slowly in the middle of transitioning
to jump back in time
to show you how this wound up happening.
the Hoyt is that Dar-Benn using the second bangle
to create the false jump points
or the messy jump points.
And then Monica Rambeau interfacing
with one of the jump points in all their powers
being based on the same basic
principle causes them to be entangled together.
there's a little bit of hand-waving,
like don't try to get too deep into the weeds
on how this works because it probably won't hold up.
but basically the idea is that
their powers are based on the same principles,
like they come from the same source fundamentally,
and that's why they're entangled
They jump back a couple of days and show you lost
memories that Captain Marvel was trying to get back.
What she was held captive by the Kree
all those years using the same
scroll memory device that we saw during Secret Invasion
during the first movie.
Moseley there to set up the big twist with the memory
device later in the film, when they all three use
it together, They also kind of use this for speed run
version of the first captain Marvel movie.
For people that didn't watch the first movie
or just haven't seen it in a long time
and don't remember what her backstory is.
these scenes of her destroying the career
supreme intelligence are based on deleted scenes
from the first Captain Marvel movie.
But they change that.
They spruce it up just a little bit
so it looks a little bit nicer.
their couple moments.
Also setting up some of Monica's big twist
later in the movie where Nick Fury is telling her that
she has to glow like Aunt Carol, which she does
at the end of the movie when she's fully powered up.
also that she can fly in, meet her halfway,
which she does during the movie.
And Monica can fly in the movie,
like all the stuff that she does in the film
are things that she does in the comics.
It's just we haven't seen her do them yet.
They're couple of sweeps they do across their ship
to just show you what her living quarters are like.
And there are a lot of artifacts
leftover from the nineties,
but also there's a lot of stuff
that she has like pictures of Monica as an adult.
When she joined Sword
for the first time, pictures of Maria before she died.
she's a couple reading books like Isaac Asimov,
some classic sci fi lot of nineties music to a lot of
beastie Boys that they played later in the episode,
mostly because she is from the nineties.
So like, that's her taste in music they reintroduce
goose the cat who they revealed actually
was staying with Monica and Maria during the five year
time to at least up to the point that Maria died.
Then Carol took goose the cat and became her cat
basically
it's meant to be the same goose,
the cat from the events of the first movie.
But in real life they recast the cat.
So it's like different cats in real life
that are playing.
It's two different cats called Tango in Nemo.
The play Goose.
one of the weird details
you notice is she wears really loud crocs.
but also because we're talking about Loki season
two finale.
Loki himself was wearing some weird loafers
in the finale when he made his
for God of Stories outfit.
a lot of talk about people
shoes in the Marvel Universe.
This week.
do kind of back and forth
on how intelligent Falcon are in the MCU.
Like, I think they're meant to be kind of smart,
that they're more intelligent than regular cats.
But they're probably not
quite as intelligent is like the smarter animals.
Like dolphins, for instance.
Like goose.
The cat can operate the coffeemaker, the basic buttons,
the floor can later in the movie
can listen to Nick Fury in the others
commands about eating the other people
so they can carry them down to the planet.
Speaking of which, they also revealed
that Captain Marvel has been keeping in regular contact
with Nick Fury
since everyone came back in Avengers Endgame,
and they revealed his saber space station
that he built with the help of the Skrulls.
But this has been happening in the background
for a while.
They've been teasing the Saber space station
for a while, finally revealed.
What's been going on with that
since the Spider-Man far from home Post-Credits scene.
Think about how long ago that movie was.
It feels like it's been 84 years,
they actually revealed during the Secret Invasion
series that the Saber space station
is actually funded by the US government.
It's kind of like shield.
Like SHIELD was funded by the U.S. government.
But generally the movie
kind of ignores the events of Secret Invasion like Nick
Fury feels like a completely different character,
and he doesn't really address anything that's going on
with the skrulls at all.
they don't even reference TALOS
The other skrulls that are living on planet Earth
and they're like a million skrulls that were living on
planet Earth during secret invasion.
the saber space station is based
on the sort of space station from the comics.
Joss Whedon, who directed the first two Avengers movies
and started Agents of Shield,
also created the Sword Space Station in the comics.
surprisingly, it was inside the X-Men comics.
There's a lot of X-Men stuff happening in this movie.
He calls Captain Marvel the prodigal child
of the Milky Way, because the scroll races live
in a totally different galaxy,
or they're from a totally different galaxy.
she's been spending most of her time
since the nineties in that other galaxy
since she killed the Supreme Intelligence.
She kind of explains later why she never came back.
It's mostly because she felt like she messed up
so badly, killing the supreme intelligence.
It destabilized the entire galaxy
and she's been trying to fix everything since then.
But they do explain that she did come back to Earth
in flashbacks during the five year time jump.
There's this whole relationship that she has,
like she has this really close friendship with Valkyrie
that they explained her in the movie.
I think that'll happen during the five year time jump.
don't worry.
We'll get to that.
They're like a lot of big questions that the movie
raises, like, when did this become a thing?
What's going on?
Notice Nick Fury also acknowledges goose like,
is that goose because it is the falcon
that took his eye out.
they said at the whole jump
point storyline in the episode
explained that the original Quasar used
the quantum bands to create all the jump points
and now their destabilize is because Dar-Benn
is basically creating false
or like janky jump points it's basically
hurting the entire network in effect stabilizes enough
Eventually
there'll be a giant collapse in a much bigger incursion
that we see at the end of the movie.
That's so big
they couldn't stop it destroying the MCU universe.
In the X-Men universe.
then I believe when they mentioned Planet Movie 418
where she found the second Bangle,
that's meant to be a reference to Captain Marvel Volume
four, Number 18, which was a genocidal
storyline involving the Naga bands, which are kind of
like the quantum bands, but there are different story.
It also involved Thanos in Thor in the costume
the Captain Marvel gets at the end of the movie,
like the brand new suit
looks just like Jezebel's costume.
They start referencing what Monica Rambeau has been up
to, what her powers are like now.
They show a lot more of her powers.
She's become a captain's.
They call her Captain Rambeau, but it's also meant
to be a reference to her being the original female
Captain Marvel In the comics and in the movie,
they call the three way Team Up the Marvels,
because at different points,
all three of them use the Marvel name.
They remind you
the Captain Marvel doesn't need a spacesuit.
Apparently, neither does Goose the cat either.
it also they reveal this is the first time Monica has
spoken to Captain Marvel since she was a little girl.
Like they hadn't met in person
until later in the movie.
they swap for the first time after they come
into contact with the jump point at the same time
and basically explain that they always swap places
when they use their powers at the same time.
so if you're confused about why sometimes they swap
and sometimes they don't,
if they only use their powers one at a time,
they don't swap.
If they do,
then they do swap so, in order for all three of them
to swap at the same time,
they all have to use their powers at the same time.
Otherwise just two of them will swap.
They use this first action scene to sort of explain
how that all works for some comedy kind of tease Kamala
Khan's family, whole idea of them dealing with
Captain Marvel, who winds up in their living room like,
hey, what's going on? Nice living room. See you later.
Then they go to the Tarn AX Planet where the Scrolls
Sect is living is a big, deep cut from the comics.
Is the original location where the Super Scroll
came from in the new throne world of the scroll empire.
In the MCU, though, Gaia, Amelia Clark's character,
Taylor's daughter, is basically the new super Skrull.
they finally reveal Emperor Draghi
this is his sect it's living on this planet here
the Taylor's mentioned
during the Secret invasion series
now they don't completely explain
why all the scrolls didn't move to this planet.
Maybe just couldn't support a million plus scrolls
or why these scrolls didn't come to planet Earth.
Who knows?
but basically they're in the middle of the peace talks
between the Kree in the scrolls that they reference
at the end of the Secret Invasion series
Durban, is basically just using it as a front
because she's going to steal their atmosphere
no matter what, but eventually winds up
blaming it on Captain Marvel showing up.
But that's just meant to be a ruse.
Like it's going to be an excuse.
when they have the next fight in Kamala Khan's house,
the Cree call Captain Marvel.
The annihilate her again.
They do that several times in the episode.
I kind of would explain the principle
behind the Annihilator concept.
They also use the fight to show you some of Monica
Rambeau's powers in a way they haven't shown you before,
like the way
that she can actually turn herself invisible,
so to speak,
or basically go out of phase with this dimension
That's how she can pass through objects,
she can pass through the floor,
she can pass through walls, she can let things pass
through her Notice when Nick Fury shows
up, though again, Kamala still thinks
this is part of the Avengers tryouts for the new team.
when she references
Nick Fury is pad thinking it's the new Apple iPad.
This is the setup
her stealing it at the end of the movie to try and form
the young Avengers with Kate Bishop's help
but also they don't mention Apple products
or really like any products just in general inside
Marvel movies, for the most part,
usually you have to pay tens of tens of millions
of dollars of product placement for that to happen.
So either Apple paid them a dump truck of money
to have Ms
Marvel reference iPads in the movie
or this might have something to do with the theory
that everybody thinks
that Apple will eventually by Disney.
So the sort of cozying up
to each other in the background.
So if you start hearing people referencing
Apple products in Marvel movies all the time,
then you know something is up with that.
that's why in all the Spider-Man movies,
they always reference Sony products
because Sony owns the Spider-Man character,
and they also make a lot of consumer products.
Quick has Spider-Man reference
says Sony found that he's using a couple more times.
We want people to buy more phones,
when they come back to Kamala Khan house.
Notice that she's wearing a t shirt that has real life
Captain Marvel comic book covers on it.
they revealed that Saber stands for Strategic Aerospace
and Bio physic in Excel Linguistic response.
basically a bunch of different aliens
from across the universe, all living together,
dealing with space based threats.
it's kind of what sword was designed for in the comics,
but they kind of burned
the Sword organization during Wandavision,
which is why they had to create Saber for this movie.
Otherwise it would have been Sword.
Nick. Very.
Also confirms that he's kind of got Kamala
under surveillance.
Kind of.
He says he keeps an eye
on all superhumans on the planet, so to speak,
or special people who have superhero potential.
Monica explains.
It's because of the events of this Marvel season
one, like, you're the hero of Jersey City.
Of course we keep tabs on you because you have powers.
basically everything that happened in that finale
episode, if you haven't seen it, they swap again.
And finally have the big Captain Marvel Monica
Rambeau reunion.
It is a little bit weird
because the two characters have never met on screen,
like we've only seen her
with the younger version of Monica Rambeau,
so they kind of had to create this chemistry
between the two of them.
Lieutenant Trouble is what she used to call her
in the first Captain Marvel movie.
then she explains the events of one division
and how the hex gave her powers
by mutating her DNA, making her a mutate
kind of like Spider-Man and the Hulk mutates.
And mutants are like two completely different things.
so, in order to be a mutant, you have to be born
with the gene like Kamala Khan was or like name
or is there technically mutants mutates or people
like Spider-Man or the Hulk, for instance, or not.
Now, Monica Rambeau, who grew up normally then had
their DNA mutated by some experiment or some accident.
the difference between X-Men characters and mutants
is that X-Men
characters are just people
who were actually on an X-Men team.
which we actually see at the end of the episode
when we see some actual X-Men characters
Monica flies for the first time.
She can fly in the comics.
He just hasn't done it.
As she explains in this moment then they wind up
switching and clocking the other Bengal captain.
Marvel catches up with them
super quickly using the different jump points.
they enabled quick travel mode for Captain Marvel
during the movie, Then they basically set up
the Valkyrie Thor cameo during the movie,
like they had Thor characters basically for New Asgard.
They explained the captain
Marvel became friends with Valkyrie.
I think they implied that it happened
during the five year time jump
when she was visiting Earth
a number of different times,
working together with all the surviving Avengers
Valkyrie gives her a pep talk and reveals
that she has a nickname for Carol Danvers,
just calling her Marv, as in Marvel.
then basically takes
the surviving Skrulls back to New Asgard.
So now pretty much every single Skrull that's left
alive in the universe now living on planet Earth.
based on the numbers during secret invasion,
it's like a little over a million.
maybe, maybe they'll move them
to, like, some other planet eventually.
But for now,
I think they're going to stay on planet Earth.
the reason why Valkyrie's wearing a business suit
when she shows up instead of a suit of armor
is because she just normally wears a regular suit
while she's being king or queen of Asgard.
Have you want to think about it?
the unintentional teams that she references
are from Thor Ragnarok in Thor, Love and Thunder.
there's a quick speech that they have on hold
for talking about the restoration of their race.
A lot of people asking about this, too,
like why are some of the Kree blue skin?
Why are some of them pink skin?
explain during the first movie
that there are some pigskin Kree in there,
some blue skin, Kree like Ronan the accuser.
so basically Dar-Benn in a lot of these other creatures,
just pink skin.
Kree Monica Rambeau explains
more from the plot of Wandavision referencing a witch,
giving her powers by traveling through a witch's hex
because of Scarlet Witch.
also the Back with Sword about how she got grounded.
When they got bullet back
in how they had them investigating earth
based anomalies instead of space based ones.
And that's how she wound up
going to the hex in the first place.
basically because Tyler Hayward was trying to engineer
a way to reactivate white Vision.
these are getting into the drama
between the two of them.
I kind of already explained this earlier in the video
about why Captain Marvel didn't come back sooner
Kamala Khan is sort of like the Spiderman
of this adventure in space.
Coming up with all the pop culture references
she makes a copyright joke apologizing
for using Captain Marvel's name.
Like I've been using the Marvel name
this whole time. Is it okay?
She starts brainstorming a bunch of code names
for Monica Rambeau.
Some of them are based on actual comic book names,
and some of them are just like mash
ups inspired by already Marvel characters in the MCU.
Professor Marvel feels kind of like Professor Hulk.
Captain Marvel
then explains the whole legacy behind the quantum
bands of Quasar Kamala
also recaps the events of the Ms
Marvel series again
when she traveled back in time in space,
basically revisiting her great grandmother's memories.
when she calls Ronan the accuser's universal weapon,
the Cosmo ride,
like I was going to call it the Cosmo ride.
That's also a thing from the comics.
The Cosmo rod is the cosmic control rod,
which is an artifact from the negative zone
that a denialists, who we also referenced earlier
with the whole Annihilator
Easter egg winds up using to conquer the negative zone.
Then they basically use the scroll memory device
to get the location of all Donna from Ms.
Marvel's mind,
but also use it for a bunch of flashbacks.
They can show you more of the history between
Maria Rambeau, Captain Marvel, that five year time jump
when she did visit Earth.
more of the relationship between her and Monica Rambeau
the whole idea is that she came back
during that five year time jump while Maria was still
dying of cancer in agree to take Goose the Falcon.
this is a couple of lines of dialog
sitting at the post-credits scene to
when she says
she never wanted to become Captain Marvel.
Like Maria saying, I never wanted to be this character,
but they've actually done a couple of versions,
that character already,
where she became Captain Marvel in Doctor Strange
two in the 838, and also in this X-Men universe.
At the end of the movie.
they also explain how she wound up being the person
to actually get the powers.
They basically said that on that day
they were both racing for the hangar
and there was a bet between the two of them
and she won the bet by arriving at the hangar first.
Otherwise it would have been Maria Rambeau
to get in the accident and get the powers
they're couple more flashbacks to the events
of Wandavision in Monica Rambeau getting snapped back,
I think the ring that Monica is wearing around her
neck on the chain is probably her mother's old ring
generally a big week for multiverse related stuff
between this and Loki Season two, they said that
the whole twist with Goosed the Falcon giving birth
when they start noticing the eggs all over the place.
Kamala Khan starts
brainstorming more Codenames for Monica.
Firefly is actually a villain from Marvel Comics, a
relatively small time villain that fought the defenders
in Nova Separately,
Nightlight is actually the name that Kamala
was going by before she chose the Miss Marvel name.
That's what they were calling her
when she was first figuring out her powers,
running around, trying to be a superhero.
So it's sort of like she's trying to use her
old code name for Monica Rambeau.
count as Marvel
feels sort of like a mashup of counters, as in Val
that we met during Falcon the Winter
Soldier in Captain Marvel Mistress
Marvel is just a riff on Ms
Marvel, which Monica Rambeau never actually used,
is a codename in the comics
Because when she was introduced in the comics,
she just went straight to becoming Captain Marvel
because at that time,
Carol Danvers was still called Ms
Marvel for a long, long time. Dr.
Marvel felt kind of like a doctor. Strange riff.
Dr. Brite is actually close to Emily Bright,
who's relatively recent doctor Strange, magic
based character they mentioned Nova,
who we know that Marvel will introduce at some point,
like there's actually a pretty big Marvel character.
Supernova Girl just seems like a riff on Binary,
who we do see in her mother at the end of the movie.
Captain Marvel also kind of goes full binary
when she reignites the Cory's son
at the end of the film to They mentioned Spectrum,
which was one of Monica's names in the comics.
Briefly,
Spectrum Vision is just a riff on Vision's name,
which they say is already taken
like, Nope, can't use that.
Already taken.
there's a big montage where they play Beastie Boys
intergalactic because most of Carol Danvers
music tastes is from the nineties
so Beastie Boys nineties music
the actual song played on all the trailers
and there's a bit of an Easter egg in the song itself.
One of the lines says, Don't tell me to Smile.
That's a reference to the events of the first movie
where a lot of people were complaining
the Captain Marvel was not smiling enough.
they said the whole conceit of the Aladdin, the Planet
and the fact that you can only communicate through song
and it is something from the comics.
Prince John is a comic book character,
but from the Captain Marvel Comics.
this is one of those like really weird parts
of the movie they either love or you hate.
Like all the singing in the dancing,
She explains that she became a princess of this planet
because she technically had to marry him
so that he could keep his throne
because they rule by matriarchy
and otherwise he would have lost throne.
they also end the movie and she hasn't gotten
a divorce, so she's still technically married to him.
mostly I think they put this in the movie
just because they wanted it to be super wacky
and so they could have a big song and dance number and
have Brie Larson actually sing as well as Prince John.
he's played by Park SEO Jun.
Some of you might recognize him from some other movies.
He's actually a pretty famous actor,
But if you didn't realize it, Brie Larson
is a musician in real life, like she's
mostly known as an actress, but she's also a musician.
She's played a lot of musicians in previous movies
as well, so it's actually her singing during the movie.
notice.
While all this craziness is going
on, Monica Rambeau is double fisting drinks.
Then it seems like they have some kind of magical
or energy
based power
that allows them to transform their clothing.
He basically morphs her clothing into a gown
that looks just like her uniform.
And it's also how they explain them
getting their new versions of the suits.
Later. Monica Rambeau also references Ms
Marvel's fanfiction,
which she writes in the comics and also in the MCU.
they roll out the new suits.
In suggesting more nicknames for Monica,
they say Lady of Light.
That's actually something that was referencing
the original Monica Rambeau
Comics news,
the wings that they try to put on her suit.
That's actually a reference to Monica's original suit
when she became Captain Marvel.
they mentioned Frequency and Pulsar?
Pulsar was another name
that Monica Rambeau used for a while?
Kamala Khan suit,
as far as I could tell, is not from the comics.
I think they just created it for the movie
in the whole twist with Kamala
Khan, using her scarf as a weapon
is something from the comics.
as they're escaping, Kamala mentions, captain,
my captain, she was referencing Dead Poets Society.
But the actual quote from Dead Poets
Society was them in that movie quoting
Walt Whitman later, when Monica calls Captain Marvel
the mighty Captain Marvel.
That was the name of one of her actual
comic book runs in real life.
they hatch all of goose, the cats falcon eggs,
which hatch into four kittens
like they call them floor kittens.
When they set the whole conceit behind them, basically
eating all the crew of the space station.
This got a little wacky for me.
Like they come back to the space station,
they start playing Phantom of the Opera music.
I don't know why they chose that song in particular.
They make it kind of seem like a massacre,
even though technically they were saving everyone
by putting it in their stomachs.
So do you not wonder now what it is like inside
the stomach of a falcon is a kind of like a TARDIS.
Like, is it bigger on the inside
when they're crashing to earth,
they pass by the golden Statue of Liberty,
which we saw during Spider-Man.
No way home.
But notice
this one doesn't have the golden Shield anymore.
Maybe they just destroyed the shield
during that final fight in Spider-Man.
No way home, in.
Durbin winds up getting Ms Marvel's other bangle and.
When she's activating them,
she clings them together, forming an X symbol,
kind of foreshadowing the X-Men teaser that we see
just a little bit after this.
she can't handle the extra power.
It winds up destroying her and tears
a whole between universes.
But I think the reason why Ms
Marvel can wear both bangles
and survive is because of her x gene, her mutation.
a lot of people also asking about the second bangle
at the end of the movie,
like why does she only have one bangle?
What happened to the other one?
I think they decided that they were too powerful
to be kept together, too dangerous to be kept together.
So they just stashed the second bangle somewhere else
secretly.
Captain Marvel goes back to reignite the sun
by going binary.
Like I said, flying through
it is core maxing her powers out.
seems like the Kree Skrull war
is essentially over at this point.
then back at Monica Rambeau's house,
they're basically moving in Captain Marvel like she's
taking over the house, watching over it, as she says,
while Monica Rambeau is stuck in that other universe.
Kamala Khan bond
that Monica Rambeau is stuck in the other universe
and they don't have their little three way
Marvels team up anymore.
Likes the idea of being on a team
so much She decides to put together
a team of young superheroes,
which will be the MCU version
of the Young Avengers, kind of combined
with the comic book version of the Champions.
her first stop is to go to New York City
and try and recruit Hailee Steinfeld.
Kate Bishop in the scene is meant to be
a parody of the Iron Man one post-credits
scene with Nick Fury showing up to recruit
Iron Man for the original Avengers
Most of
her speech is also meant to play out
like a parody of Nick Fury speech.
Like the dialog is the same or very similar.
Notice. Kate Bishop is wearing her newer suit.
She's coming back from a night of super hearing.
Pizza Dogg also makes a cameo in the scene, too,
with another pizza reference.
she also jokes to Kamala Khan
that she's not a teenager.
Like I'm in my twenties.
What are you talking about? Teenage superhero team.
She winds up begrudgingly agreeing to be on
Kamala Khan's team, even though she doesn't really
like the idea of being on a team quite so much,
which is very much like Kate Bishop from the comics.
She's kind of like that in the comics.
Ms Marvel then starts rattling off other superheroes
that she wants to be on the team
next In mentions
Ant-Man has a daughter, Cassie Lang she's referring to.
Then we have the actual Mid-Credits scene.
the big X-Men scene.
So Monica Rambeau
wakes up in the hospital room of the ex mansion
inside the other universe next to her mother and Rambeau.
who in this universe also became
a version of Captain Marvel instead of Carol Danvers.
But she's going by the binary name from the comics
and wearing the more modernized version of binaries
costume from the original comics she also became part
of the X-Men team in that storyline.
So for instance, this version of Binary in the MCU
is part of this X-Men team.
but essentially she's like a more powered up
version of Ms
Marvel.
Captain Marvel seemed like a way
more powerful version of the character
then because they're in the expansion,
like they're in the middle of an X-Men team,
we see that beast is treating them both, and it's
Kelsey Grammar back as the version of the character
the big difference this time though
is that it's completely motion capture.
He's not wearing a beast prosthetic suit
like he was during X-Men Last Stand
Monica Rambeau has no idea what's happened.
Like she doesn't know who the X-Men are,
so she thinks this is actually her mother, Marie Rambeau.
But in this universe, they explained that
Maria never got married, never had children.
So Monica doesn't exist in this universe.
She has no idea who this woman is.
in the whole idea of it wasn't clear.
This isn't meant to be like the main X-Men universe
from the Fox movies.
It is meant to be a different universe
where a version of the X-Men exists,
like it's not the A38 universe or anything like that.
But it does mention Charles Professor
X wanting an update.
So Patrick Stewart
also back as another version of Professor X
For the most part this is meant to be a set up
for the events of Deadpool three where we'll see
a bunch of classic X-Men actors coming back
as different versions of their characters
from different universes.
then there's kind of a hidden post-credits
scene over the very end of the credits.
So it's more of a funny moment.
Doesn't really have anything to do
with the actual plot of future movies.
It's meant to be a flick in making cat sounds,
just an audio form over the actual end credits.
And it's meant to be a reference to the Avengers
endgame and credits scenes
with the banging Iron Man
sounds over the credits from that first Iron Man movie.
one of the other notable changes
that you probably detected in the Post-Credits
scenes is the very end of the movie.
There's no kind of teaser message
about any of the characters returning, like
Captain Marvel, Miss Marvel, Monica Rambeau,
even though we know all three of them will be back.
Normally, at the end of Marvel movies, they say
Captain America will return or Thanos will return.
But at the end of this movie, there's none of that.
if you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the movie that I didn't
mention in this video or my previous videos,
just write them below in the comments.
I've got a bunch more Loki videos I'm working on in
my next video will be my invincible.
Season two Episode two Video that should be up later
tonight, so be sure to enable alerts for my Chelsea.
Don't miss that Click here for my full Loki Season
two Episode six
Finale video and click here for The Marvels
movie Post-Credits Scene Video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.